[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
mercredi 18 octobre voici le programme
de ce soir les yelines compteront
prochainement 22 brigades de gendarmerie
de nouvelles vont être créées sur le
territoire d'ici 2027 et uel Macron l'a
annoncé début octobre une brigade fixe
sera implanté à Ben et une brigade
mobile à rambouillé les détails en début
d'émission puis-je emmener mon animal de
compagnie au travail est-ce que le faire
venir au bureau réduit le stress à la
mairie de poissie certains agents ont
décidé de passer le cap depuis le 1er
juin ils sont autorisés à venir
travailler avec leur boule de poil
bouclier chevalier damoiselle ou encore
soupe médiévale le weekend dernier
châaufort a fait un bon en l'an 1000 la
traditionnelle foire de la Saint-Simon a
battu son plein avec environ 10000
visiteurs et puis l'invité du 78 en 2e
partie d'émission le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline organise sa
Golf expérience ce vendredi 20 octobre
l'occasion de découvrir gratuitement ce
sport sur un site olympique et on en
parlera avec Maxime Lucas bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes chargé de la
promotion de la vie sportive pour
Saint-Quentin en Yveline avec nous
également sur ce plateau un journaliste
de la rédaction de tv78 Michel d'
bonsoir bonsoir vous allez nous
présenter les informations à retenir
aujourd'hui dans les ivelines mais avant
nous allons prendre la direction de Ben
et de rambouiller je vous le disais à
l'instant début octobre Emmanuel Macron
a dévoilé la création de 238 nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie en France dans
les ivelines deux unités seront mises en
place d'ici 2027 c'est le reportage de
Julien
Leroi plus de gendarmes dans les
ivelines le 2 octobre dernier le
gouvernement annoncé la création de deux
nouvelles brigades dans le département
d'ici à 2027 une réflexion menée depuis
janvier 2022 et les annonces du
président de la République en début
d'année le ministre de l'Intérieur
géralde darmana rencontrait des élu
yvelinois sur la commune desbrévières
pour mieux cibler les préoccupations le
fruit de cette concertation a été le le
résultat de deux constats le premier
c'est une augmentation sensible de la
délinquence sur le temps long au centre
du département le deuxè ça a été
également une augmentation de la
population en zone gendarmerie qui crée
pour demain et sur le temps long un
besoin de sécurité supplémentaire à Ben
une unité fixe verra le jour avec une
dizaine de gendarmes présents ils
s'installeront temporairement dans ce
local prêté par la commune avant une
implantation définitive la réaction
était de joie puisque cela fait
plusieurs mois qu'on était en relation
avec le groupement de gendarmerie pour
voir la possibilité je dis bien la
possibilité d'installer une brigade de
gendarmerie sur ben tu vas pas être que
pour Ben bien évidemment mais
certainement pour les autres communes
qui sont aux alentours dans le sud des
iveline une unité mobile axée sur
l'environnement sera basée à Rambouillet
lutte contre les dépôts sauvages les
nuisances sonores ou les feux de forêt
feront partie de ces missions C
gendarmes pourront se déplacer dans
l'ensemble du département n'a pas
vocation en première intention à
accueillir le public sa vocation sera
clairement de patrouiller d'aller
constater des infractions et d'accomplir
un travail de police judiciaire sous le
contrôle du procureur de la République
de Versailles et donc c'est un travail
d'enquête avec ses créations le
département des Yvelines cont de
brigades aujourd'hui les effectifs sont
évalués à près de 700 gendarmes et 450
réservistes alle laissezleur à présent
de faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et on commence avec cette
information le château de Versailles a
encore été évacué aujourd'hui après une
alerte à la bombe et c'est déjà la
troisème fois que cela se produit en une
semaine après des évacuations samedi
dernier et hier le site des iines a dû
fermer ses portes et évacuer plus de
10000 visiteurs à la mi-journée comme
les deux précédentes alertes le
signalement de cette menace a été
réalisé via la plateforme
moncommissariat.fr faux salaire donc
encore une fois le château de versaill
est resté fermé pendant près de 3h le
temps qu'une levée de doute soit
effectué par les équipes de déminage il
a rouvert ses portes vers 15h ce matin
avait lieu une table ronde pour
améliorer l'attractivité économique de
la France c'était ce matin dans la salle
du conseil communautaire de 550 an à
trappe cette réunion a été menée par
Charles Rodwell le député de la première
circonscription des iblines depuis près
de 6 mois le parlementaire est chargé
par la première ministre ellisabeth
borne d'une mission auprès du
gouvernement le but améliorer
l'attractivité des investissements
étrangers en France après avoir déjà
visiter une trentaine de départements il
s'est donc rendu dans les iines ce matin
pour rencontrer des entreprises des élus
et des services de l'État afin de
recueillir leurs besoins et leurs
attentes sur cette thématique et nous
reviendrons sur ces échanges dans notre
édition de demain vous nous parlez à
présent d'un concept jamais vu en
Île-de-France la première pierre du
projet premium a été posée hier au cœur
du quartier de l'hyercentre de 50 ans en
liveline ce site qui regroupe deux
bâtiments doit accueillir le premier
concept de civing d'î-de France nouveau
type d'habitat est une forme moderne et
améliorée de la colocation les habitants
disposent d'espaces privés tout en
partageant certaines pièces comme le
salon le jardin ou une salle de sport
mais peuvent également travailler
directement sur place grâce notamment un
espace de coworking on écoute les propos
recueillis par Clara de Frutos le
concept Babel c'est un concept de
bâtiment hybride qui mène à la fois de
l'hébergement mais également du
coworking un restaurant une salle de
sport beaucoup d'événements un lieu
propice à la rencontre puisque nos
clients se rencontrent au sein d'espace
commun d'espace collectif très nombreux
du sport du restaurant mais également
plein d'espaces communs des jardins
partagés au sein même du même bâtiment
globalement c'est avant tout une réponse
à la à la difficulté de se loger dans
les grandes métropoles notamment de la
part des jeunes actifs sur ce site qui
est derrière moi on va construire un
ensemble de 13000 m² composé enité de de
de deux deux unités il y a une opération
de coliving colorking de 10000 m² pour
Babel
community qui qui va regrouper 245
chambres
hôutelière destiné aux jeunes actifs et
un immeuble de 3000 m² de bureau
indépendant le prochain numéro de skych
mettra en lumière plus largement ce
projet à premium Mathilde direction
Mantel jolie avec un événement qui va
intéresser les jeunes ivelinois en
recherche d'une formation le campus
départemental Paul sésane situé dans le
quartier du valfouret organise demain sa
journée portes ouvertes c'est de 10h à
17h l'objectif répondre au manque de
qualification des jeunes bénéficiaires
du RSA au total 14 organismes de
formation seront présentés des métiers
de bouche du B bâtiment au service à la
personne en passant par la sécurité ou
encore le numérique depuis son ouverture
l'année dernière le campus a déjà permis
la formation de 750 jeunes et enfin on
termine ces informations avec une
exposition qui va replonger certains
d'entre nous dans notre jeunesse tomt et
Nana est-ce que ça vous dit quelque
chose Mathilde bien sûr Michell j'avis
quelques Tom ément et bien la
dessinatrice de la célèbre bande
dessinée Bernadette Despré était hier
soir au Musée du Jouet de poissie
présente pour l'inauguration d'une
exposition dédié à son œuvre elle vous
invite à découvrir dans les moindres
détails l'univers des deux enfants
terribles et les personnages qui les
entourent l'exposition est visible dès
demain et jusqu'au 7 janvier prochain je
pense que vous allez y faire un petit
tour Mathilde peut-être je vais voir
merci beaucoup Michel midoro pour toutes
ces informations et comme d'habitude si
vous aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
communiquer sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hhtag 78
news
il est parfois compliqué de laisser son
animal de compagnie à la maison pour
aller travailler depuis le 1er juin la
mairie de poissie permet à ses agents de
venir avec leur boules de poil ATIS Baré
conseillère municipal en charge du
bien-être pour la ville de poissie nous
emmène à la rencontre de Toby et de
Daisy et bien sûr de leur
maître bonjour je suis bar donc
conseillère municipal à la ville de
poissie et aujourd'hui nous sommes donc
en mairie nous sommes venus voir les
agents de la ville de poissie qui ont le
privilège de pouvoir travailler avec
leurs chien nous allons voir Nathalie
qui est aujourd'hui en compagnie de
tolby bonjour Nathalie bonjour Toby tu
dis bonjour Toby tu dis bonjour Merci
Toby nous
[Musique]
accueillir ça a beaucoup changé niveau
de du midi pour le sortir et tout ça
c'est vrai que je cours moins mais et
puis ben c'est c'est quand même plaisant
d'avoir son petit compagnon avec avec
soi au travail ça me ça m fait du bien
bon il a un petit peu peur il est un
petit peu craintif mais il a il a il il
s'est beaucoup amélioré depuis depuis
qu'il vient avec
[Musique]
moi installé donc elle a ses croquettes
son eau elle est bien au frais voilà
elle a son petit coussin voilà ses
petits jouets ah ouais
Toby
[Musique]
sympa nous allons aller au service
communication de la Ville de poissie
nous allons à la rencontre de deszy qui
vient travailler avec Julien allons les
voir
bonjour Julien bonjour coucou dy ça va
comment ça a changé ton quotidien ouais
bah ça a tout changé quasiment chaque
jour ici ouais et on a pris nos petites
habitudes nos petites habitudes
quotidiennes donc là fait le tour du
service elle dit bonjour à tout le monde
ou parfois même eux oubli de me dire
bonjour à moi temps je vais essay de la
laisser un petit peu à la maison pour
que qu' qu'elle comprenne que ce sera
pas chaque jour qu'il y aura des fois où
on pourra pas dans l'équipe ça a ouvert
peut-être d'autres personnes qui parle
maintenant plus depuis que DESY est là
ouais c'està dire que on est on est déjà
dans une équipe qui qui fonctionne bien
mais c'est vrai que ça fait un petit un
petit truc en plus ça fait un je sais
pas oui comme une petite mascotte un
petit bien encore dans dans l'équipe tu
lâches pas le morceau moi non plus dés
hein je lâche pas le
[Musique]
morceau jusqu'au 14 janvier 2024 le
musée de la toile de joui à joui en
Josas et consacre une exposition sur les
motifs mais aussi sur le métier de
designer textile longtemps resté anonyme
certains créateurs mettent aujourd'hui
leur nom en avant c'est le reportage de
Julien
Leroi qui se cache derrière ces œuvres
colorées au musée de la toile de joui
l'histoire du métier de designer dans la
création textile est retracé du 18e
siècle jusqu'à nos jours impression la
planche de bois rouleau de cuivre ou au
laser les techniques ont rapidement
évolué pour cette profession destinée à
l'industrie l'exposition motifs
d'artiste rend hommage à ses créateurs
on se posait la question mais d'où
viennent ces motifs on parle tout le
temps de des motifs de toile de jouille
de ces scènes à personnag mais qui sont
les auteurs de ces fameux motifs quel
était leur statut on se rend compte
qu'au 18e siècle tous ces dessinateurs
étaient totalement anonymes une
reconnaissance acquise avec le temps dès
la fin du 19e siècle le métier de
designer textile se mêle à celui
d'artiste permettant une plus grande
émancipation des noms comme William
marice émergent ce Britannique célèbre
pour ses motifs floraux intemporels mais
en Autriche il y a aussi un mouvement
similaire la vinire vateur et là donc on
a un prêt de la bibliothèque Fornay avec
plusieurs échantillon d'artistes qui
donc deviennent dessinateurs imprimeurs
mais qui vendent aussi leurs motifs et
on a des motifs tout à fait étonnants
mélange d'inspiration et de techniques
diverses cette exposition met aussi en
avant des réalisations plus récentes dès
le milieu du 20e siècle des artistes
commencent à collaborer sous leur propre
nom avec les marques on a aussi donc des
œuvres parfaitement contemporaines ici
c'est une robe qui date de 2022 donc les
motifs ont été dessinés par le créateur
de mode Christian Lacroix et c'est une
robe qui est vendue par des igiles en
fin d'exposition le public est invité à
dévoiler ses talents en dessinant les
habit d'un petit personnage de papier
motif d'artiste à jou en Josas est à
retrouver jusqu'au 14 janvier 20
24 durant une journée les habitants et
les visiteurs de Châteaufort ont voyagé
dans le temps la traditionnelle foire
Saint-Simon était de retour le weekend
dernier chevalier princesse ou encore
fou du roi on foulé les rues le
reportage de Michel elmidoro et de
Aurélie
[Musique]
lafel les cuux et les passionnés ont été
ravis le dimanche 15 octobre c'était le
retour de la fête médiévale à
Châteaufort le centreville s'est vêtu de
ses plus beaux blasons et banderol pour
la 37e édition de la sint Simon près de
10000 personnes se sont retrouvées pour
vivre à la manière des habitants du
Moyen-Âge dans une ambiance conviviale
et
familiale comme chaque année de nombreux
artisans proposé animation et stand pour
découvrir les coutumes aimés d'autrefois
c'est c'est la grande fête du village la
foire Saint-Simon tous les 3è dimanches
d'octobre bien sûr tout le village se
costume il y a les stands de galettes
les jeux pour les enfants les spectacles
enfin oui c'est c'est un incontournable
du village oui prendre des galettes des
crêpes des endouillettes des châigne la
taverne médiévale qui est là et qui est
qui est superbe avec des bons repas le
jus de pomme au pressoir et la soupe
médiévale à ne pas manquer dans son
immense chaudron sur la place le public
a assisté à un spectacle inédit au vol
libre d' de faucon de bu et d'autres
rapasses ils se sont détendus avec les
animaux de la ferme le public pouvait
aussi découvrir des activités
traditionnelles comme le pressage de
pomme manuelle ou l'entraînement au
combat de chevalier c'est une fête de
village qu'on a mis en place il y a une
quarantaine d'années par des amoureux de
l'histoire du médiéval qui qui ont voulu
faire une fête et et qui ont créé cette
foire un voyage dans le temps pour
lequel certains visiteurs jouent le jeu
je suis venu l'année dernière pour la
première fois j'ai bien aimé parce que
c'est très familial c'est très
sympathique châau fort vous accueillera
l'année prochaine pour sa 38e édition
avec au programme les mêmes ingrédients
qui ont fait recette cette
année et c'est bientôt l'heure de
l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin le temps sera mitigé
nous devrions avoir quelques averses sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines côté température
il fera assez doux compté 15°gr à oudans
et montelas jolie et 14°gr à Versailles
et rouillé durant l'après-midi les
conditions météo seront semblables
prévoyez des averses au niveau des
températures il fera 17°r à rambouiller
18 à Houdan et Versailles et 19 à
mantelajolie et demain nous fêterons la
Saint-René c'est l'heure maintenant de
passer à l'invité du
et on va parler de golf dans cette
partie invitée ce vendredi 20 octobre le
Golf National de Saint-Quentin en
evveline propose plusieurs initiation
dans une ambiance festive pour en parler
avec nous Maxime Lucas chargé de la
promotion de la vie sportive pour
Saint-Quentin en Yveline alors qu'est-ce
qui attend les ivelinois pour cette
nouvelle édition c'est juste avant les
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2020 2 ça va
être un petit peu différent je suppose
ouais alors on on change pas le format
global de l'événement et les objectifs
qui sont ceux de de l'événement golf
expérience c'est un héritage de la rider
Cup qui a été accueilli à 50 ans en
Eveline en 2018 et du coup
l'agglomération a mis en place une
politique de promotion du golf sur son
territoire et donc golf expérience
répond à deux objectifs pour deux cyipes
différentes euh donc on on a l'ambition
de proposer au golfeur une une version
euh un peu plus folle du golf avec une
version nocturne on joue avec des balles
lumineuses sur un parcours qui est
éclairé grâce à des sticks lumineux on a
un practice donc c'est l'endroit où on
s'entraîne à faire ses coups euh qui est
mis en lumière et qui est euh ambiancé
par un DJ euh et donc le la deuxième
cible euh de cet événement bah c'est de
faire découvrir le golf donc là on on
parle à des des débutants complets des
gens qui n'ont jamais touché un un club
de golf de leur vie et donc là on a une
une brigade de bénévoles golfeur qui est
qui est présente et qui euh qui VI
donner des conse qui vientnent donner
des conseil et leur leur apprendre leur
premier leur premier coup donc cette
année quand même vous avez installé un
un village olympique ouais c'est la
c'est la nouveauté cette année c'est
c'est l'un des des derniers événements
organisés par l'agglomération de 50 an
nieline au golf national avant les jeu
euh donc forcément il y a à moins de 10
mois des Jeux là il y a il y a un angle
et un axe
jeu qui va être diffusé sur tout
l'événement via la présence de ce
village et donc dans ce village on fera
la on parlera de ce qui va se passer
pendant les jeux à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline présentation des des sites
olympiques parce que le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en yvelin on va le
rappeler c'est bah un site des Jeux
Olympiques il va se va il va se dérouler
des épreuves olympiques sur ce golf
ouais le le golf national il va
accueillir 8 jours de compétition 4
jours pour les hommes puis 4 jours pour
les femmes euh avec chaque fois une
autour de 30000 spectateurs qui vont se
se réunir au Golf National donc ça va
être un lieu fort de de l'olympisme sur
le le territoire et même à l'échelle du
pays
euh puisqu'on est sur l'une des plus
grosses jauges en terme de spectateur de
l'ensemble des équipements euh et donc
et il répond aux autres aux autres sites
pardon du du territoire et donc c'est
important pour 50 an neline de le mettre
en avant à travers cet événement et de
l'ouvrir on a souvent des des gens qui
sont pas golfeurs et qui ont peur de
rentrer dans un golf et donc là au
travers de cet événement c'est c'est
justement leur montrer que les portes
sont grande ouverte que que le golf
national mais aussi les autres golfs du
territoire sont accessibles au débutants
que plein de Golf propose des des
initiations et donc là on va leur parler
jeu avec bien évidemment la présentation
des sites la présentation des épreuves
la présentation de la du site de
célébration qui sera mis en place par
l'agglomération sur le territoire et on
va aussi leur parler programme bénévole
puisque l'agglomération va avoir des des
domaines de
responsabilité avec l'accueil et
l'orientation du public depuis les gares
jusqu'au sititees de compétition et
aussi vous cherchez encore beaucoup de
bénévoles ouais ouais ouais il y a il y
a ces deux missions qui est l'accueil et
l'orientation des spectateurs et aussi
l'animation de la Fan Zone et donc pour
ça on a estimé à peu près à 500 le
nombre de de bénévoles nécessaires euh
et on a on a un programme bénévole et un
questionnaire qui a été mis en place sur
notre site skierlesjeux.fr h euh et donc
le le questionnaire est toujours ouvert
on est toujours à jusqu'à quand les gens
peuvent rentr les G peuvent s'inscrire
jusqu'à la fin de l'année euh on est en
train d'étudier les les premières
candidatures elles sont déjà nombreuses
on est très content c'est on on sent un
vrai engouement pour les jeux sur le
territoire les les habitants et même
au-delà puisqu'il est ouvert vraiment à
tous
euh sont vraiment enthousiastes à l'idée
de de recevoir des des spectateurs du
monde entier chez eux ou à 5 an euh et
donc on envie d'être acteur de cet
événement et alors petite surprise
vendredi vous allez aussi pouvoir enfin
vous allez offrir des places pour les
Jeux Olympiques ouais c'est c'est un peu
ce qu'on le gros teasing autour de cet
événement c'est qu'il sera possible de
gagner des places pour les
jeux on a tous fait la la recherche pour
avoir des places sur les jeux et on
s'est tous plus ou moins retrouvé face à
un mur et elles sont très cheres aussi
elles sont très chèes et ça a été très
dur d'en avoir euh mais la aglomération
a réussi en avoir quelques-unes en a
acheté quelques-unes et donc elle va en
faire bénéficier enfin il va y avoir
quelques place mise en en jeu vendredi
soir au golf national ce sera des places
pour aller voir le golf ou pour aller
voir d'autres sports alors ça sera
principalement des places pour aller
voir le golf mais il devrait y avoir des
places pour aller voir d'autres épreuves
qui se dérouleront sur le territoire et
alors c'est un événement qui attire
combien combien de personnes combien de
visiteurs En moyenne est-ce que c'est
plutôt
familial alors c'est c'est un événement
qui est qui est très sympa je dis pas ça
parce que c'est nous qui
l'organisons mais c'est un événement qui
réunit des familles des amis euh les
gens viennent souvent soit parce qu'ils
ont ils sont golfeurs et ils ont envie
de tester le le golf nocturne et donc
ils viennent à à l'horaire de leur
départ mais on s'aperçoit qu'il restent
après pour boire un verre rester
oui parce que c'est aussi festif il y a
des guinguettes il y a un DJ ça et cette
année en plus on
aura la possibilité de de voir le la
demi-finale de la Coupe du monde de
rugby sur place on a mis des écrans pour
pouvoir enfin qu'on nit pas cette excuse
de je ne peux pas venir parce que il y a
la demi-finale la deminale Argentine
Nouvelle-Zélande malheureusement la
France n'est plus dans la compétition et
ça n'empêche pas de suivre cette grande
compétition qui se déroule en France
donc il sera possible de l'avir et voilà
donc c'est un événement où il y a des
aussi des activités d'initiation pour
les enfants euh et donc on s'aperço aur
quoi comme atelier par exemple une cible
géante où vraiment l'idée c'est de c'est
de marquer des points donc un une
approche du golf très ludique on a mis
en place des petits ateliers pour pour
voilà faire des premiers puts ou alors
un chamboule tout géant où on va
propulser des des gros barils à l'aide
de balle de golf euh donc l'idée c'est
c'est vraiment la la même sur toutes les
ateliers de de l'événement proposer une
version très fun du golf euh et une
approche différente de la de la l'entrée
très classique qu'on veut d' VO
d'habitude au golf c'est pas trop
compliqué de de jouer la nuit au golf
vous avez mis des balles fluorescente ou
ou enfin voilà des des des zones pour
des de lumières pour qu'on puisse
repérer mais ça complique un peu la
chose quand même alors sur la sur le le
parcours nocturne
là les les vrais joueurs de golf qui qui
accèdent bah c'est c'est différent c'est
c'est un peu plus compliqué de de
trouver sa balle enfin un délai en plus
entre le moment où on la tape et le
moment où elle s'arrête de clignoter
donc il faut être assez rapide pour la
retrouver mais ça ça propose vraiment
une version différente du golf
euh on n'est pas là dans un cadre
compétitif voilà et donc les gens sont
vraiment là pour le fun et et s'amuse et
sur les ateliers d'initiation il y a
l'éclairage nécessaire pour pour que ça
soit pratique faisable et pas dangereux
donc donc c'est vraiment ouvert à tous
merci beaucoup Maxim Lucas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions alors si vous
êtes intéressé la Golf expérienceé ce
vendredi 20 octobre pardon au Golf
National de Saint-Quentin en niveline et
ça se passe de 18h à minuit et l'entrée
est libre et gratuite juste avant de se
quitter une annonce demain soir c'est le
retour de la météo du weekend présenté
par Thomas Fetcher et il revient plus en
forme que jamais regardez on travaille
dur on travaille dur toute l'année
franchement on peut pas se reposer il
faut du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
REP alors quoi de
bon allez c'est la fin de ce 78 merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous